une dernière séance de préparation avec
sa garde rapprochée
justin trudeau est sur la corde raide
une rare comparution de premier ministre
l'ultime tentative pour apaiser la
tempête
l'organisme unis n'a pas reçu de
traitement de faveur ni de moi et de qui
que ce soit d'autre
la fonction publique a recommandé
l'organisme unis et je n'ai absolument
rien fait pour influencer cette
recommandation justin trudeau assure
qu'il n'a pas entendu parler du mandat à
unis avant le 8 mai pour gérer le
programme de bourses au bénévolat
étudiants il aurait même retarder la
décision pour s'assurer que la fonction
publique avait fait ses devoirs
mais l'opposition a riposté soulignant
la proximité entre la famille trudeau et
l'organisme saviez vous êtes ya conflit
d'intérêts malgré que vous le saviez
vous n'avez jamais demandé vous retirer
je n'étais pas en situation de conflit
d'intérêt je ne suis pas en situation de
conflit ou d'excusé pour cela à cause de
la perception et lien avec ma famille ça
aurait été plus facile et j'aurais dû me
retirer ses adversaires ont multiplié
les attaques concernant les sommes
payées ou remboursé par unis à des
membres de sa famille qui ont participé
à ces événements par match des voyages
humanitaires payé par unis au ministre
des finances et sa famille ont placé le
premier ministre sur la défensive
vous savez je me gêne que monsieur
morneau avait en voyage avec eux légende
weir
non je ne je ne savais pas
particulièrement qui avait est en voyage
avec avec lui mais je savais qu'il y
avait une fille qui était impliqué
tentant de rester calme justin trudeau a
réitéré sa confiance en son équipe de
ministres sans surprise l'opposition n'a
pas été convaincue par son témoignage
hulot repousser le petit ange de les
deux secteurs avec son sens son réflexe
monarchique habituel
le premier ministre a assuré avoir été
prudent mais sept experts se demandent
pourquoi dans ce cas il ne s'est pas
récuser
s'il avait tellement conscience des
problèmes que pourraient rencontrer le
contrat le premier réflexe à avoir est
est précisément de se récuser faso à la
décision